hasta que éste se perfora.
Ahora, la razón por la que todos en la sala de operaciones
estaban mirando ese dispositivo ese día,
era porque tenía que ser absolutamente cuidadoso
para no hundirlo
y romper los órganos y los vasos sanguíneos debajo.
Este problema debe parecerles muy familiar a todos
porque estoy seguro de que lo han visto en otro lugar.
(Risas)
¿Recuerdan esto?
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Sabían que en cualquier momento
la pajilla iba a atravesar,
y no sabían si iba a salir por el otro lado
directamente a su mano,
o si se regaría el jugo por todos lados.
Estaban aterrorizados, ¿verdad?
Cada vez que hemos hecho esto,
se experimenta la misma física elemental
que yo estaba viendo en la sala de operaciones de ese día.
Y resulta que realmente es un problema.
En 2003, la FDA en efecto dijo
que las incisiones de trocar pueden ser el paso más peligroso
en cirugía mínimamente invasiva.
De nuevo en 2009, vemos un artículo que dice
que por los trócares suceden más de la mitad
de las principales complicaciones en cirugía laparoscópica.
Y, ah, por cierto,
esto no ha cambiado desde hace 25 años.
Así que cuando ingresé al postgrado en la universidad,
esto era en lo que quería trabajar.
Estaba tratando de explicarle a un amigo,
qué era exactamente en lo que estaba invirtiendo mi tiempo,
y le dije:
"Es como cuando estás haciendo un hueco en la pared
para colgar algo en tu apartamento.
Hay un momento en el que el taladro termina la perforación de la pared
y entonces su hunde, ¿cierto?"
Él me miró y me dijo:
"¿Quieres decir que es como cuando hay que taladrar el cráneo de una persona?"
Y yo le repliqué: "¿Perdón?" (Risas)
Entonces lo investigué y supe que los cráneos de las personas también se perforan.
Una gran cantidad de neurocirugías,
en realidad, empiezan taladrando una perforación a través del cráneo.
Y si el cirujano no tiene cuidado,
puede llegar fácilmente al cerebro.
Ese fue el momento en que empecé a pensar,
bien, perforación craneal, cirugía laparoscópica,
¿por qué no, otras áreas de la medicina?
Piénsenlo bien, ¿cuándo fue la última vez que fueron al médico
y no los chuzaron con algo? ¿Verdad?
La verdad es que
en medicina, las punciones están por todas partes.
Y estos son solo 2 de los procedimientos que he encontrado,
que involucran alguna punción en un tejido.
Si tomamos solo 3,
cirugía laparoscópica, anestesia epidural, y perforación craneana;
en estos procedimientos suceden más de 30 000 complicaciones
cada año, solo en este país.
Yo llamo a eso, un problema que vale la pena resolver.
Así que echemos un vistazo a algunos de los dispositivos
que se utilizan en estos tipos de procedimientos.
Mencioné la epidural. Esta es una aguja epidural.
Se utiliza para perforar los ligamentos de la columna vertebral
y dar anestesia durante el parto.
He aquí un conjunto de instrumentos de biopsia de médula ósea.
Estos son usados para excavar dentro del hueso
y tomar muestras de médula ósea o de lesiones óseas.
Aquí hay una bayoneta de la Guerra Civil.
(Risas)
Si les hubiera dicho que era un dispositivo de punción médica
probablemente me habrían creído.
Porque, ¿cuál es la diferencia?
Así que, cuanto más investigaba
más pensaba que tenía que haber
una mejor manera de hacerlo.
Y para mí, la clave del problema
es que todos estos dispositivos de punción
comparten unos mismos principios de física elemental.
Entonces, ¿cuáles son esos principios de física?
Volvamos a la perforación de una pared.
Uno aplica fuerza al taladro hacia la pared.
Y Newton dice que la pared ejercerá una fuerza contraria,
igual y opuesta.
Así, cuando uno perfora la pared,
esas fuerzas se equilibran.
Pero luego viene ese momento
en que el taladro termina la perforación al otro lado de la pared,
y justo en ese momento la pared ya no puede hacer más fuerza.
Pero tu cerebro no alcanza a reaccionar a ese cambio súbito en la fuerza opuesta.
Así que por un milisegundo,
o el tiempo que te lleva en reaccionar, todavía estás empujando,
El desequilibrio de fuerzas provoca una aceleración,
que es cuando se hunde.
¿Y si en el preciso momento de la punción
uno pudiera tirar de la broca hacia atrás,
oponiendo, en realidad, a la aceleración?
Eso es lo que me propuse hacer.
Así que imaginen que tienen un dispositivo
con una especie de punta afilada para perforar un tejido.
¿Cuál sería la forma más sencilla de tirar de esa punta hacia atrás?
Elegí un resorte.
Cuando uno extiende el resorte, se extrae la broca
y queda lista para perforar el tejido,
el resorte halará la punta hacia atrás.
¿Cómo mantener la punta en su lugar
hasta terminar la punción?
He utilizado este mecanismo.
Cuando se presiona la punta del dispositivo contra el tejido,
el mecanismo se expande hacia afuera y la asegura en su lugar contra la pared.
Y la fricción que se genera,
la bloquea en su lugar y evita que el resorte retracte la punta.
Pero justo en el momento del final de la punción,
el tejido no puede empujar más la punta.
El mecanismo se desbloquea y el resorte retrae la punta.
Déjenme enseñarles lo que suceda en cámara lenta.
Cerca de 2000 cuadros por segundo.
Fíjense en la punta.
Está en la parte inferior, a punto de pasarse a través del tejido.
Verán que justo al terminar la punción,
en ese mismo instante , el mecanismo se desbloquea y retrae la punta.
Lo mostraré de nuevo, un poco más de cerca.
Van a ver la punta afilada.
Justo cuando se perfora la membrana de caucho,
la punta se esconde en esta vaina roma blanca.
Precisamente ahí.
Eso sucede 4 centésimas de segundo después de la perforación.
Como este dispositivo está diseñado para actuar según la física de la punción
y no es específico para la perforación craneal,
la cirugía laparoscópica u otro procedimiento,
es aplicable a todas estas varias disciplinas médicas
en diferentes rangos de longitud.
Pero no siempre es así.
Este es mi primer prototipo.
Sí, esas son paletas de helado,
y hay una banda de goma en la parte superior.
Esto se hizo en solo unos 30 minutos, pero funcionó.
Se demostró que mi idea era válida
lo cual justificó el trabajo en este proyecto, los 2 años siguientes .
He trabajado en esto porque
este problema realmente me sedujo.
Me mantenía despierto por la noche.
Creo que debería fascinarles a Uds. también,
porque, como dije, la punción está en todas partes.
Eso significa que en algún momento este también va a ser su problema.
Ese primer día en la sala de cirujía
no esperaba encontrarme al otro lado de un trocar.
Pero el año pasado, tuve apendicitis cuando estaba viajando por Grecia.
Cuando estaba en el hospital en Atenas,
el cirujano me dijo
que iba a realizar una cirugía laparoscópica.
Me iba a quitar el apéndice por esas pequeñas incisiones,
y me hablaba de lo que podía esperar para la recuperación,
y lo que podía a suceder.
Añadió: "¿Tiene alguna pregunta?" Y yo dije: "Solo una, doc.
¿Qué tipo de trocar usará?"
Mi cita favorita sobre la cirugía laparoscópica
viene del doctor H. C. Jacobaeus:
"Es la punción en sí la que causa riesgo".
Esa es mi frase favorita porque H. C. Jacobaeus
fue la primera persona en realizar una cirugía laparoscópica en humanos,
y escribió esto en 1912.
Este problema ha estado lesionando e incluso matando gente, por más de 100 años.
Es fácil pensar que para cada problema importante,
existe algún equipo de expertos trabajado día y noche para resolverlo.
La verdad es que no es siempre el caso.
Tenemos que mejorar en la búsqueda de problemas
y en encontrar las formas de resolverlos.
Si se encuentran con un problema que los atrape,
dejen que los desvele.
Déjense fascinar,
porque hay muchas vidas por salvar.
(Aplausos)